hey you guys happy Friday and thanks for
tuning into eg live I'm Katy Kraus and
the cast of the honor list is all here
Sasha Arden Meghan thank you guys
my best friend Meghan this movie was
your brainchild essentially so now that
it's out it's available now for you guys
to all watch how does it feel
are you overwhelmed excited first one
variable yeah it's just really weird
yeah it's always felt kind of weird once
it stopped just being this thing in my
head and then like these characters were
real people and then like they exceeded
my expectations and then the movie
exceeded my expectations and now it's
just this like thing that we made I got
used to being comfortable with all these
people who did the movie us all knowing
this story and I like other people are
gonna know and all of that so I think
it's just like a whole other it's like
opening up a whole other world to it so
I'm just like I don't know what's
happening yeah I'm I'm so proud of you
I'm dying I have no idea what's
happening for you guys all watching and
tuning in make sure you send your
questions for these lovely ladies I'm
gonna get them right here on this iPad
you said that you saw the movie it
exceeded all your expectations watching
back the movie for you guys same
feelings oh yeah like way way more
you're just like you're so touching and
I think for me to not always being there
for all the scenes it was so nice like
watch it sort of as an audience member
yeah the first time I saw the video that
you did there's something over at the
end spoiler my heart was just ripped out
like it it just it was so special I feel
like we have so many special moments in
this movie that is is rare yeah this
movie isn't just I think what people
expect it's it's about growth and about
change and about grief and it's really
special kind of give the viewers a
little bit of a synopsis because I would
almost compare it to like a now and then
or like a Sisterhood of the Traveling
Pants type of movie would you get more
girls can relate to
there's a lot more topics that you don't
generally see girls do in movies and
yeah I feel like yeah I mean it's it's
about four girls who were really great
friends growing up and then by the time
that they get to their senior year we
flash-forward and we have no idea why
they're not friends anymore
and throughout the movie it's kind of
figuring out how they've grown apart to
be these super different people but then
also trying to figure out how they once
were these really good friends and what
happened between them and so we get to
follow them at the very pivotal point of
graduating high school and kind of when
things just come to a head because
you're no longer gonna be around these
people all the time
so it's kind of like the last time
you're in that pressure cooker and we
figure out what happens them because
they come back together to a bucket list
yeah when there's some tragedy good what
I love about it too is that it's very
real I think there's a little bit of an
illusion that teenagers don't go through
hard things and that girls don't do
certain things right exactly and it's
it's obviously false we all go through
some crazy stuff and there's no age cap
on that you know so I think it's really
great that it's something that's
realistic yeah we go through hard things
at every point in our lives there's no
secret and to touch on that and to kind
of put some light on the fact that you
should be yourself and not hide it is
very special I also think in this
industry there's like a lack of strong
female characters and we're getting to a
place now where there's more and more of
it but this movie really came out ahead
of that it seems like how important was
that I mean it's a female crew and
female characters it's called power yeah
I mean as a gender we've been around
equally as long so I don't know why it's
taken so long yeah and yeah I mean it's
just something like the amount of if
you're not in the industry it's hard to
explain that you walk onto a set and
you're lucky if there's two girls and if
those two girls aren't in makeup or hair
that's even more rare like if someone's
miking you who's not a dude like that's
like whoa this is a great day like this
is something that's so rare and
different no that's good um but it's
just so rare and so different and
there's something that makes you more
comfortable
and you can feel more vulnerable and
safer when you're doing something like a
movie about women needs to be made by
women because a male director can't he
can have a sister he can have a mom but
he can't understand what it's like and
even just the way you shoot that like
the way patty Jenkins shot Wonder Woman
that was the way it wasn't shot like
most of the time how male directors
shoot females and movies and you can
tell like she's not sexualized she's
this like strong character and that's
what's so important with this too and
like we were eight I don't think there's
so much stuff we did in this movie that
I'm like I don't know if I would have
done if we didn't have a whole crew of
women who were like - it's fine sweetie
you're good you're good you're good it's
like it just feels I don't know it's not
only that were be able to do the job
with all women I think the movie the
movie is as great as it is because of
that it wasn't like we did it in spite
of only like really focusing on hiring
women who like don't always get an
opportunity to chance like it the movie
did better and is a better product
because of that sure there is a scene
that I was wanting to ask you guys about
it's when you guys are in the high
school gym and you take on these evil
mean cheerleaders you guys actually
stripped down is that was that you was a
body double no it was us it was okay it
was renamed it snatch patch there's the
thing we can't when you when you see us
being that naked now imagine we have to
be much more naked on the day to get us
looking that naked so we had to stick it
and then some and we had some really fun
curveballs
except I like a like a fireball that was
a rainbow spectacular yeah so that was
weird - in front of like 300 extras well
talk about the significance and the
importance of that as it relates to the
movie well it's definitely see it's the
fear that you would have that was I
promise it was the scariest thing I've
ever done I've gone skydiving some
really dangerous stuff and it nope that
it doesn't compare nothing we are losing
our minds like giggling uncontrollably
don't be like I can't do it
can do it we're gonna do and then Sasha
just like comes over and she goes we're
gonna do it in 1 2 3 ready and I think
oh right someone had to do it you're
like hey guys come on how many takes was
that like did you have to do it multiple
times they were very nice because it was
several stages of yeah okay yeah so we
had like nude Bandos at first and then
we layers upon layers upon layers we're
just we were like lobsters being put
into boiling water like slowly turning
it up slowly and crying oh it was I
think it was great because we actually
um what we're getting back it's a Cheers
the cheerleaders for we shot that scene
the really emotional heartfelt flashback
scene like two days before yeah and so
really fresh yeah and it made it so like
I was watching it and then as I was
watching the scene with like headphones
on watching them do this great scene I
was like I can't wait to strap like I'm
not nervous anymore great really
powerful yeah because we felt like we
like you get so heated in that that
you're like no I want to do that like I
feel like I have to yeah because she
made me cry so hard and I'm not a crier
at all oh my gosh in that scene in that
scene that we had she oh I love this
movie because it really shows off the
acting chops I mean I've watched you on
so many different things and I know you
guys on like your YouTube channels but
it really shows a depth like a different
thanks dad so yeah it was different to
get into that mindset what was that I'm
like I don't know I think for me it
wasn't as hard as I thought it was gonna
be cuz you know I I was home-schooled so
it's not like I had that gymnasium
experience or that dealing with
cheerleaders I didn't have that but I
mean I don't know about you guys but we
deal with a lot of social pressure
always and it was just it was just a
different way of experiencing that and
it felt very real and I mean I was going
through and still me I'm like a lot of
weight issues and finding out you know
about PCOS and all of that stuff it was
very real and all in that moment um so I
didn't have to try very hard just just
kind of happens just yourselves yeah and
our
and our extras who are in that scene a
they were going through it with me it
was the same thing they found out that
day that's that was what they were going
to work to do which is a very scary
thing yeah and we were all kind of in it
together so it it didn't feel like
acting it just it was very raw and
emotional and it and I think that's part
of the reason why it came across so well
on screen was because it was a real
moment but that's why we love you is
because you've almost become this or you
have become this role model and it
sounds like you were so honest and
candid on Dancing with the Stars and
following that and even here today and I
think people are learning from you yeah
I mean I'm they're learning as I'm
learning which i think is a really cool
way of using social media that's a
positive way of using social media and I
feel like that's what it really should
be about yeah going back to the whole
scene was that inspired by something
that happened did you test yes so that
happened they did it a little
differently but they did it at the
college I went to a different sorority
not a real thing that happened yeah but
they so they did a dance version they
also did one where they made girls sit
on washing machines what and then I was
like first of all who if you sat on a
washing machine who wouldn't jiggle like
that's it'd be a bad washing machine if
it's not like leaving your clothes not
like it would have to do yeah and so
that was something that like it was like
a fear that I had cuz like you hear that
when you're a freshman like rushing
sororities and I was like oh my gosh oh
I can't join this one because of that
thing that happens right and then going
through that and being super nervous
that like that's gonna happen one day
so ya know it was it was I never
thankfully never had to go through that
but like I had heard all of these horror
stories of girls who had it was so sad
I'm shocked that that is still a thing
it's 2018 but that exists right still
also it's like butts being so in trend
I'm like we're not allowed to jiggle but
you want us to have butts like I don't
know what you make up your mind yeah
have you guys had to deal with any Mean
Girls in Hollywood I know you didn't go
to high school but has that been yeah I
mean I won't name names
of course and I think it's actually it's
it's all about insecurity right and it's
a projection and you know that they're
feeling so insecure about their own body
and what they think that they should
look like so when they see what they
think is an imperfection on somebody
else
it's they're quick to judge you and I
think it takes a lot for someone to say
it to you in person it's easy to do it
over social media I got into a fight
with a troll who was attacking you she
was my guard dog I will never forget
that I like I would pay someone if
someone said I need those things to me
would not care but I was just like it's
like this visceral reaction to be like
no it's anyone you care about right you
see these words and I mean I've learned
to really just brush it off you have to
but I remember Hudson being like did you
see yeah I mean I think like it happens
always and I've definitely I've fallen
to like the cycle of like when you don't
have like a really solid group of
friends you can kind of take because I
think especially like in women that
nastiness can always be disguised as
something else
and there's those like subtle digs and
those subtle cut downs that they just
they can continue on so I found myself
in like friendships with people like
that where you're like wow I'm in this
like massive toxic toxic friendship
that's so manipulative and it wasn't
until that I was able to really get out
of that cycle and make really good
friends that now when people treat me
badly I'm like no no I know what this is
I don't need you I have nice people like
I don't need to have this but like it
when you're especially here like when
like a lot of people like I mean I
didn't graduate college like a lot of us
like move here young and you don't
really know anybody and you can kind of
just you want to find that like like
that like found family and that kind of
thing so you can sacrifice that a lot
but I feel like everyone goes through
that especially like I mean I moved from
the Midwest ten years ago so I met a lot
of mean people yeah but then you get
through it and you get all
and it's so easy to spot like I feel
like I see it right away - yep and it's
like when you see a mean girl you're
like up she's a mean girl yesterday but
now like it doesn't bother me as much
and I always feel bad when I meet Mean
Girls because I'm like you must be so
unhappy with who you are to be exuding
so much like it's so much an effort yeah
I was gonna say it takes so much effort
to be mean right it's so much easier to
be nice yeah yeah no I completely agree
you said he moved here 10 years ago I
know that you're a 32 but you look
amazing thank you
it's not it's not fair like I'm angry
like I'm like happy for you but also
upset James no you look so funny is I
feel like this movie as we talk a lot
about like women empowerment it has been
empowering me as well because this whole
process like I am shocked that it like
happened so quickly but really like I
was very hesitant because I love the
script and loved the project I really
loved everything about the story but I
was like oh I'm just too old because
this business makes you feel too old it
shames you it makes you feel like you're
not good enough you're not pretty enough
you're not skinny enough you're not tall
whatever yeah and so I realized that
like I've kind of been holding myself
back a lot because there's a lot of
things that I've been like oh no I'm too
old for that or I'm not right for that
and I guess you know in this situation
Alyssa really was Fermin was like no let
me decide that
mm-hmm and I believe in you and I think
you're great and everybody knows so
don't worry you're not like tricking
anyone okay
there's literally the first thing I said
when she was like let me just meet with
you and I was like okay fine I'll I'll
meet my age it was like please just have
a lunch with her yeah I was like okay
because you guys but that's the thing
like when we all first met yeah I didn't
for a second in that moment feel like
out of place but it's just funny because
you just you put a judgment on yourself
we are where the we're so mean to
ourselves sometimes yeah yeah we're very
mean and we're very hard critics I think
everybody is and so I think when you
realize you're doing that you've got to
stop yeah and I think I'm just realizing
that now this year that I'm very mean to
myself and self-love we yeah yeah it
takes um
questions are coming in no one on
YouTube says what was it like working
with Zoe Saldana she's one of the
producers of this right yeah yeah yeah
she's a beautiful human first of all
yeah I love everything about she's
exactly what you want her to be you meet
her in person you're like I loved
working with I just love working with
her production company because they had
signed they got ahold of the script not
like that sounds like they like broken
and stole the script really early on
because they had heard a production
company and they were really focused on
female stories and diverse female
stories and so immediately they are
really interested we had this meeting
and the first thing they said is that
stuff we love this script and we love
how diverse like this cast needs to be
and I was like great don't change your
mind because everybody's gonna want to
change their minds eventually because
it's such a heart it's at such an uphill
battle to fight for yeah and so it was
so nice knowing the whole time I'm like
I have those like three kick-ass sisters
who are on my side the whole time of
being like nope we need this we need
this we need this we're not changing
this character because we're not going
to make this person somebody else like
this is gonna be something that all
these girls can watch and relate and see
a different character make that could be
me that could be me that could be me and
like your whole group of friends can
watch it and you can all be somebody
yeah because that's what happens like I
could relate to sister the Traveling
Pants and all of my like friends and my
guys go really cool so you get to be
Blake Lively and us we get to be nobody
no it's like that so I think that was it
was really nice to have that knowing
that we had the same goal Yeah right
and ultimately like I knew that they
were not gonna wave around that either
which was great yeah Nicole from
facebook says of Sasha getting married
yes very soon that's right a couple
weeks this month yes a couple weeks
you'll definitely find out when you see
it I can't say too much right now BAM
you're gonna love it
it's overseas though right it is yes
Ireland it's a destination wedding okay
yeah why'd you choose that destination
um it's one of our favorite places it's
beautiful most of my family's in South
Africa so it's it's a good meeting point
and yeah what are you most looking
forward to about being married and I
just took Mary to my best friend
I know I you know I've gotten a lot of
advice about how it is gonna feel
different and I think what's special
about that is it's like it's like you're
dating again it's a new spark not that
we need it but the point is is it's kind
of a fun change he's honestly he's the
best and and he's my my biggest
supporter and he's my rock and and he's
just I mean he's the best person I know
we can all find that right yes yes oh
yeah and don't settle until you have it
yeah well these ladies be at the wedding
you know why we just sorted whispering
no it's I'm gonna have a big reception
here so that everybody I make it but
it's it's really it's family it's all
family there are you guys playing your
own vows we're gonna do it a little bit
differently my best friend is marrying
us and we we've written our own set vows
and then we're going to do our own
written vows personally with just a
videographer just the two of us so that
it's yeah it's a little bit more
personal so I'm excited I love that we
were talking about the dress earlier are
you going like classic traditional
princess sexy what's I the original
dress that I had in my mind was actually
really sexy mhm I loved and then I ended
up seeing this something completely
opposite it was like this ball gown and
it was off the shoulders and it was
beautiful and that's actually where I
went and I was kind of like it's the
perfect location like if I'm gonna do a
princess dress that's where I'm gonna do
yes so it's um it's kind of modern kind
of princess and I mean the Train is just
it's excessive yeah have you guys seen
pictures yeah exit yeah yeah I see yeah
okay I've been sending her pictures of
like random wedding Instagram accounts
of like pictures do they take a picture
like this take a picture like there's
one with champagne and like a castle a
bagger I'm like you gotta do this one
yeah who's gonna cry first you or Hudson
probably you probably me yeah yeah yeah
emotional don't be so emotional too
though I think as soon as I think this
is you cry
okay yeah whoever cries first the other
primal cry because of that my best
friend three year longer than I've known
Hudson and he's known my best friend
year longer than he's known me okay and
I have a feeling she's gonna cry first
which will make both of you yeah yeah
it'll be the three of us all crying I am
I have it says a bad word in it so I
can't say it online but it's it says
keep your together
it's a hankerchief and then everybody
else has really nice pretty things
there's the mind like feeling that I
will definitely yeah I feel like that
when he sees you that might be when he
just yeah it could be put my best on
that yeah um Celia from facebook says do
you guys recognize yourself and your
characters or not at all hmm I mean I
like hate to say that I do because there
are certain things that Piper would do
it oh my god we're the same and this is
not an attractive quality
or like things like that um but yeah
there's definitely there's definitely I
mean be having a hand to the story since
the beginning there's definitely stuff
that I like personally related to that
she's going through or he's gone through
um but personality-wise the her she's
super insecure and just deflects it with
pretending she doesn't care which was
high school me and current me to a tee
yeah we're like high school me I was
like I would be the first person to like
pull a funny face in a photo and to make
fun of myself and like be
self-deprecating so nobody could make
fun of me first sure and that's the kind
of thing like she gives off this vibe of
the reason why she's popular is because
she's too cool for everything and like
doesn't care but that it's everyone's
like oh wow I'm in front of this girl
like she doesn't care about anything
like she's so above it all but in
reality she's like is it working okay
cool like it's trying so hard to do that
which is like oh that's so me I'm like
constantly pretending I'm chill and I'm
like I'm losing it yeah oh yeah I mean I
think for me when I first read the
script initially like I was like oh my
gosh on her so much like me but then she
was a lot more confident than I was and
I feel like she's a lot like me now it's
just a little scary because then when I
watch it it makes me feel really weird
about like we were talking about it it
feels really weird especially like in
that opening funeral scene
like like my friends are watching it
like weird like when we had to get
emotional there it wasn't hard because
like all we have done is talk about her
and just see giant pictures of her in
like caskets
I met him like I was like I feel weird
about it like I loved the film but I
feel very weird about it like it was
very because all my friends watched it
last night they were like we like loved
the movie but it all it made us feel
really weird yeah and so when you do
connect with your character I think it's
a little scary cuz then it kind of blurs
that line a little it looks like oh wait
it's acting guys not a real video yeah
everything's okay
I definitely related to Isabella she's
also kind of same has this really hard
core shell and pretends like she's not
affected by anything I relate to her
especially as a teenager I feel like I
was definitely that way totally went
through that punk phase by the way is
she like always her she's got a lock
yeah round her neck that's what I did I
always had like locks and like stuff
really okay I kind of yeah I totally was
I was like yeah I was like hey can I get
a snakebite no one was like absolutely
not about me yeah I'm I was a pianist
that she actually didn't love me
interesting but I do definitely relate
to that I am lucky I had a really
connected strong family and I think
that's kind of where our differences lie
but I think it's really important to see
her character and how she grew
independently and with these girls due
to the fact that she didn't completely
have her parents support but that was a
really a beautiful way of telling that
story so I definitely did connect to her
with her struggles and with her style
but she's she taught me a lot too I
think
it was a very pivotal moment where I
started to really not be ashamed of
myself and at the same time I figured
out what was going on with me so it was
a beautiful moment and definitely timely
to play her yeah
do you miss the purple hair kind of yeah
yeah so once again
I wanted to dye my hair
we never did I never did I never did so
I'm gonna play out my moment yeah yeah
oh yeah I'm gonna take a few more of
these SPO be forever from you Joe says
Sasha
do you miss PLL we miss it of course I
immersive of course I do um every time I
Drive by the WB to the fields I miss our
crew so much and obviously I miss going
to work and seeing everybody everyday
and and the good thing is is I did the
pilot for the perfectionist yeah which
is gonna be picked up we hope so I mean
like fingers crossed right now any
minute right yeah we'll know very soon
can somebody check their email which
obviously I would really really really
love to continue playing Allison and the
pilot was so fun for many reasons but
also I really loved seeing Allison's
character grow and part of it is also
that you can't make me a teenager
anymore you can't do it done that's a
kind of fun terrible thing to say but I
feel like we were we played teenagers so
much that it was really nice to kind of
be this adult figure right it was it was
like flipping the tables it was such an
interesting perspective and way of
exploring Allison's adult side and how
she's dealt with this space that you
haven't seen yet and there's so much
room for her to grow and for the fans
just to explore which I love and you
meet these wonderful well-rounded
characters and I think the fans will
definitely if we got the chance fall in
love with these new people and their
struggles and their lifestyle and I
think you can relate to it yeah
everybody can relate to their characters
in one way or another so I think it's
really important in the pilot do we see
Allison as a mom with those twins I
don't think I can reveal that that the
twins are very awesome and they're okay
but I think Marlene won't get me get mad
and they also don't get fired okay
that's the good news that that is true I
think I think that is the one thing that
people would strike about so what about
I do I'm curious about this just
personally Allison and Mona were not the
best of friends
Mona goes to Paris at the end of PLL so
how does that come to fruition I guess
when I read the draft that we were gonna
film I I cracked up in so many spots
because of the way that they type in
their two characters they kind of become
allies in a way and it's this very
interesting kind of dynamic because
Alison's obviously not sure if she can
trust Mona shouldn't you ever trust no
no you know but the way that she ends up
being in this new town is is very
mysterious but also hilarious the way
she kind of rides over you ask questions
and I think the fans will appreciate the
mystery there there's enough told that
you know okay we'll find out but a
hilarious way of Mona putting it across
yeah yeah any cameos from anyone in the
pilot I should not say that yet okay but
that's not enough
Sanne no but it's not yes okay I like
that what was your favorite part about
the pilot um I think I think obviously
being with Janel and having the
familiarity with that yeah but also just
a new experience we shot in Portland
which was great was my first time in
Portland and it felt new and fresh but
at the same time it was that family vibe
I think we all gelled immediately and
and felt really good about it the crew
that we worked with they filmed grim and
Portlandia together and so they feel
really established and we connected just
just so well I felt like we had been
doing five seasons already yeah so I
think knowing that it it felt so good
and so strong was kind of the best part
because I was like yeah I could
definitely do this for you know a long
time for sure it's gonna happen we hope
so is it darker than Pretty Little Liars
I think it's definitely darker than how
our first season of PLL was I feel like
it picks up from PLL kind of seamlessly
there's a two-year gap around yeah
and it just it is it will be darker are
you still teaching yes yes okay
I feel very official Wow lasers and mic
it's very high-tech and vegan Heights
which I really appreciate yeah too much
more about this but Marlene did say that
not all the perfectionist are female
yeah that's right I also really love ya
house actually yeah I can see that yeah
who was in our movie
ended up being in our pilot and I kind
of freaked out I had so much fun yeah I
just saw the pictures like mm-hmm
Hugh who played my husband on PLO uh-huh
is really good friends with Chris and
obviously I know Chris and I also know
Chris his wife and he was like hey he's
coming out for this role it's like what
um
I emailed our casting director Gail and
I was like you have to hire him
immediately and he was the last
character we cast Wow we just had a ball
so yeah have you seen so fabulous the
pilot know what it's not fair I feel
like well like the cast is usually the
last people to see it
yeah yeah obviously before I fancy it
but what are you gonna do if it does get
picked up like how are you gonna
celebrate and have a dance party yeah
for sure
no I'll probably be on a plane well to
go promote it which would be which would
be amazing so yeah my gosh I'm over the
moon if that happens are you not gonna
be able to have a honeymoon oh no I will
have it's in my contract I have 300 in
my contract yeah to be able to yeah to
do that okay going back to the movie a
little bit um bucket list what's on your
guys's bucket list one thing career and
one thing personal over the next year
okay I can start at zero you can get oh
no Jimmy sorry yeah I have so many and
crew she's not here so I can take some
of hers too
yes we have almost all the same ones
except some I don't have a purse like
she wants to learn new languages and I
was like I'm good thank you hardly know
English um I think a personal one and
one okay a personal one and a career one
personal I like attainable things so I
can like cross them off list just like
set my standards low
I want a puppy really badly so like
that's a bucket list item mm-hmm not
technically again I love that cur she's
not here because she yells at me for
that one she says it's not real it's not
a [ __ ] like yeah it is now she's out
here um and then career-wise I really
really really want to be a superhero
like a Marvel movie DC movie but I would
just love that
ideally Marvel so I can be in the same
universe as Michael B Jordan and Michael
B Jordan so I would just love to do that
I just yeah I'm obsessed with superhero
movies and I always have fans it's like
I want it so bad I'm gonna fester into
the universe you can make it happen nice
about you Arden okay a personal one I
would love to travel somewhere that I
haven't been but really just to actually
do a vacation like I don't think I've
ever taken a trip that wasn't partially
work it's always something is about work
and it's yeah harshly a work trip that I
steal one day for myself and so yeah
maybe something off the grid yeah and
then work wise I would love to do like a
romantic comedy I feel like that doesn't
really happen a lot for minorities and
especially like Asian females where it's
like has nothing to do about being
asian-american but just as a human so I
think I love to work on a romantic how
many bits like relatable for yeah love
that I see yeah thanks okay I have two
career things is that all right yeah and
no it's not all right
I'm writing screenplay and I want to
finish that by the end of the year I
don't know it'll happen what I want to
do I want to work with Quentin Tarantino
that I don't that will happen in here I
doubt it that's like a that's amazing we
did my prayer I hope so and I want to
catch high with great whites which I
might be accomplishing on my honey milk
where you guys going you know we don't
know yet okay I mean some ways we just
there's are certain things that we just
don't yeah last minute I'm a chill bride
guys yeah okay you're not a bridezilla
at all at all
so chill and we're gonna wrap up but
maybe just one reason why people should
go and watch this movie it's available
today on demand on iTunes I think people
should go watch it because I think
I think it'll surprise you I think the
trailer surprises a lot of people and I
think the movie in itself too I don't
think it's a typical thing you see from
a digital release and I also don't think
it's it's so different for all of us
like it's so different than anyone like
anything that anyone's seen from
Karrueche and like the same thing from
all of us yeah and so I think I think
it'll really pleasantly surprise people
and I also think that I don't know it's
like that feel-good warm fuzzy feeling
which I usually stray very far away from
I'm like I don't like that but this this
is one that I really like so I think um
yeah I think I think people are actually
really gonna be surprised by what we
made because I think we were too and I
think it's relatable for everyone
there's really something for everyone
not just teenage girls but even women
and adults and Families there's a lot of
things touched on that don't really you
know get brought up in a lot of young
movies and so it doesn't feel young to
me I feel like a lot of people who've
watched it in different age ranges and
genders like all found something and
it's actually pretty funny yeah male
friends I loved it I know like there are
moments where you're just like yeah then
you're dying and you're crying but then
you're laughing at the same time so
you're like what does this feel like
yeah you know after you cry you grow and
I think that's what's really important
you don't you don't realize it until the
end but you actually gain something
oh yeah thank you guys so much for being
here make sure you guys that's the honor
list it's out today on demand on iTunes
all the digital places and thanks for
watching we'll see you guys next time
[Music]
you